this is sort of a a high te Heist movie
yes it is yeah so uh tell us who you
play what's going on what's happen on
Kevin Hart well gr I'm glad you asked
the question because right now uh you
know my voice may change and the only
reason why is because in this particular
film I'm an action star wow uh no he is
he really is I'm an action star I didn't
have to say it you guys can tell by
looking at my
arms uh this is a movie that takes place
uh in the air it's a i that goes on at
40,000 ft in the air and it's a thriller
it's action um with an amazing ensemble
cast and we wanted a global IP we wanted
something that the world could gravitate
towards love hold on to and watch with
whomever whenever and whatever and this
is my first leading man role um where
I'm like serious it took you a long time
huh
what you know what you know what in this
one I'm I'm not the Kevin that you knew
of I'm no no I'm just saying I was
curious yes very good good for you but
it took a long time you know you you
should start respecting me more now that
I'm an action star I'm not the Kevin
from Modern Family things have changed
things have changed for me now
[Music]
okay